こんしゅうのざっくばらん
マイクロソフトの決算
せんしゅうの水曜日（7月29日）にマイクロソフトの決算が発表され、その後、株価が15％ほど高騰しました。
1日で約五千五百億ドル（約90兆円）、時価総額が増えた計算になります。
トヨタ自動車の時価総額が約45兆円なので、その約2倍です。
理由は好決算ですが、投資家たちが最も高く評価したのは、エーアイデータセンターへの莫大な投資をしながらもキャッシュフローを黒字に保ったことです。
好決算を発表しながらも、キャッシュフローが赤字に転落した結果、株価が大きく下がったAlphabet(グーグル)と対照的です。
[EN]Microsoft (FY2026 Q4)[/EN]
[EN]Alphabet (2026 Q2)[/EN]
売上高
$90.0B
(+18パーセント)
$119.8B
(+24パーセント)
営業利益
$40.6B
(+18パーセント)
$40.8B
(+30パーセント)
純利益
$35.8B
(+31パーセント)
$34.0B
（大幅増益）
クラウド売上
[EN]Intelligent Cloud[/EN]
$39.3B
(+32パーセント)
グーグル Cloud
$24.8B
(+82パーセント)
Azureせいちょう率
+43パーセント
[EN]Google Cloud営業利益[/EN]
$8.8B
（利益率約36パーセント）
フリーキャッシュフロー
$19.6B
-$5.9B
せつびとうし(CapEx)
FY26
約$175B
年間見通し
$195〜205B
この件については、このメルマガでなんどか触れていますが、マイクロソフトは（ハイパー・スケーラーの中では）せつびとうしに慎重です。
マイクロソフトはいぜん、オープンエーアイが必要とする計算資源を優先的に提供する権利を持っていましたが、オープンエーアイがオラクルなどからも計算資源を調達することを認め、その後、この優先権自体も廃止しました。
マイクロソフトとしては、オープンエーアイ一社のためにあまりにも巨大なせつびとうしをするリスクを避けたかったのでしょう。
とは言え、マイクロソフトも千七百五十億ドルもの巨額投資をしているので、決して消極的とは言えず、これだけのせつびとうしをしながらも、しっかりとキャッシュフローを生み出している経営手腕を投資家たちが高く評価したのでしょう。
同様に良い決算を発表しながら、キャッシュフローが赤字になったことが懸念されて株価が下がったAlphabetと対照的です。
私はマイクロソフトとAlphabetの両社の株を長期保有していますが、今回の決算結果と株価の動きを見て、株価が下がったところで少しAlphabetの株を買い増ししました。
エーアイに対するじゅようは本物であり、今の時点での積極的な投資は、正しい経営判断だと私は思います。
エーアイインフラ投資
このメルマガでは、過去にエーアイインフラ投資についていくつか記事を紹介して来ましたが、ここで一度、頭の中を整理したいと思います。
まず第一に、エーアイインフラ投資のきぼですが、アマゾン、マイクロソフト、グーグル、メタの４社だけで、七千億ドル（約110兆円）超のせつびとうしがことし中に行われる予定です。
これにオラクル、xAI、ネオ・クラウドを含めると、八千億ドル超になります。
せつびとうし額は前年度から76パーセントという異例の伸びで、らいねんの伸びは少しは鈍化するとは予想されていますが、一兆ドルの大台に乗る可能性も十分にあります。
これほどまでに膨らんだ理由は二つあります。
一つはClaude CodeやChatGPTなどが生み出す「推論需要」の爆発的な伸びです。
代表的なのが、アンソロピックのエンタープライズ向けの売り上げの伸びで、2025年末のエーアールアール（年換算売上）が九十億ドルだったのに対して、ことしの5月には四百七十億ドルと、わずか5ヶ月で５倍以上に増えています。
アンソロピックは一例に過ぎません。
ChatGPT、Gemini、Cursorなど、エーアイを日常業務で使う企業が急増しており、ハイパー・スケーラーは「ジーピーユーが余る心配」ではなく「ジーピーユー不足」を心配している状況です。
もう一つは、「より賢いエーアイモデル」の開発競争で、こちらは直接の売り上げには結びつかないものの、学習プロセスにおいてより多くの計算をした方が賢いモデルを作れるという「スケーリング則」故に、学習プロセスに必要な計算能力が爆発的に増えているのです。
結果として、これまで潤沢なキャッシュフローを生み出してきたハイパー・スケーラーのフリー・キャッシュフロー（事業が生み出すキャッシュフローからせつびとうしに使うキャッシュを引いた数字）が極端に縮小しています。
それでも足らず、グーグルは新株を発行し、オラクルは莫大な借金でせつびとうしに必要なキャッシュを調達しています。
(xAIを傘下に抱える)SpaceXがじょうじょうしたのも、エーアイインフラじゅようの高まりを背景に、将来的な宇宙データセンター構想も視野に入れた大型資金調達と私は見ています。
これにより、これまで少ないせつびとうしで大きなキャッシュフローを生み出してきたハイパー・スケーラーのビジネスモデルが、せつびとうし重視のインフラ・ビジネスに大きく転換したことは、特筆に値します。
つまり、エーアイはソフトウェア産業ではなく、電力・通信と同じ資本集約型インフラ産業になりつつあるのです。
バランスシート（貸借対照表）に大きな負債を計上するのを嫌がるハイパー・スケーラーが、別会社を作ってそこに借金をさせる形の「隠れ債務」を抱えていることはいぜんから指摘されていましたが、そのきぼを計算した記事が先日話題になっていました。
Nikkeiの集計によれば、長期リースや購入契約など、バランスシート上の有利子負債には直接計上されない将来の支払い義務が、５社（アマゾン、マイクロソフト、グーグル、メタ、オラクル）合計で一兆六千五百億ドルに達し、彼らが公式に報告している債務の合計一兆三千五百億ドルよりも多い状態にあります（
[EN]A Nikkei investigation found $1.65 trillion in hidden debt at Big Tech[/EN]
スキームとしては、エーアイインフラを構築してくれる会社に対して、ハイパー・スケーラーは将来の計算能力の購入を約束し、その会社はその契約書を金融機関に提示することにより借金をし、構築の資金にするそうです。
実質的なリスクを負うのはハイパー・スケーラーですが、通常の有利子負債と同じ形では、バランスシートに計上されないのです。
CoreWeave、Nebiusなどのネオ・クラウドのビジネスモデルは、基本的には「大手エーアイ企業やクラウド企業向けに、ジーピーユー計算能力を長期契約で提供するビジネス」です。
巨額の借金をしてエーアイインフラを構築していますが、契約さえしっかりしていれば安定した収入が得られます。
ただ、その契約が実際にはどのくらい確実なものなのかが外部から見えにくいのが難点です。
こうした契約の中で最も確実なのが「take or pay(テイク・オア・ペイ)契約」です。
ハイパー・スケーラーが「ジーピーユーを使っても使わなくても料金を支払う」と約束するもので、携帯電話の使い放題プランと同じく、稼働率に関わらず固定収入が入ります。
これはネオ・クラウドにとって単なる好条件ではなく、資金調達の前提条件です。
銀行が数千億円を貸すかどうかは「返済原資が確実か」で決まるため、take or pay契約書がなければ、そもそも建設資金を集められないのです。
アナリストの中には、この特殊な契約形態こそがネオ・クラウドを支えており、ハイパー・スケーラーがこれに応じなくなった時点で成長は止まると厳しく指摘する人もいます（参照：
[EN]The Neocloud business model is brutal[/EN]
悲観論者たちは、今のエーアイインフラ投資は過剰であり、2000年のインターネットバブルの崩壊と同じ道を辿ると指摘していますが、Claude Codeを使いまくっている私は、中長期的なニーズに関しては楽観的です。
しかし、最終的にどのレイヤーの会社が利益をあげるかを予想するのは簡単ではないし、そこに至る過程で、一時的なバブル崩壊のような事態が起こり、借金を抱えている会社が痛い目に遭う可能性も十分にあると思います。
a16zのMarc Andreessenは、「エーアイが生み出す価値の99.9999パーセントは、エーアイを作る会社ではなく、エーアイを使うユーザーに渡る」と発言したことが注目されていますが（
[EN]Marc Andreessen just reminded every trillion-dollar AI lab who their real customer is[/EN]
）、エーアイが電力やインターネットのようにコモディティ化されたインフラとして普及すれば、そうなることは明確で、その意味では、Kimi K3のようなオープン・ウェイト・モデルの台頭は歓迎すべきだとも言えます。
私は、このせつびとうし競争はまだ数年続くと見ています。
しかし、その過程では勝者と敗者がはっきり分かれるでしょう。
エーアイそのものではなく、「エーアイインフラ」という新しい産業が形成されつつある今、そのどのレイヤーに投資するかが、こんご数年間の最大のテーマになると思います。
【参考資料】
[EN]Nvidia put $2 billion into CoreWeave in January 2026, a 9% equity stake at $87.20 a share[/EN]
【追記】上の記事を書いた後に目に止まった情報（
[EN]Oracle faces potential $7 billion guarantee requirement for Wisconsin AI data centre[/EN]
）ですが、オープンエーアイ向けにウィスコンシン州に建設中のエーアイデータセンターを構築しているオラクルに対して、電力を提供するWe Energiesが、データセンター向けの電力網の増強の見返りとして七十億ドル（約1兆円）の支払い保証を要求していることが判明したそうです。
理由は、莫大な借金のためにオラクルの「信用格付け」が「BBB」に下がってしまったことにあるそうです。
電力会社としては、万が一このプロジェクトが破綻した場合に、そのコストを近隣の住民に負担させるわけにはいかないからです。
オープンウェイトとアメリカのリーダーシップ
Jensen Huang氏が公開したオープンウェイトに関する以下の公開書簡が話題になっています。
クローズド（非公開）とオープン（公開）の両方のエーアイが必要だ、というメッセージが業界を超えて多くの企業から支持されている点が注目に値します。
[EN]Open Weight and American AI Leadership[/EN]
ここで言うオープンウェイトのモデルとは、誰でもダウンロードして中身を調べ、手を加え、自社の設備の上で動かせるエーアイモデルのことです。
書簡は、これを1980年代のオープンソースソフトウェアになぞらえ、オープンソースが今やインターネットの大部分や米軍・政府機関のシステムを支える共有基盤になったように、エーアイでも「一つの最先端モデル」ではなく「社会のあらゆる分野に浸透する開かれたエコシステム（生態系）」を築けるかどうかが、米国の競争力を左右すると主張しています。
書簡が挙げる利点は、大きく三つです。
経済への浸透。
ゼロからエーアイを訓練したり、あらゆる作業に最先端モデルの高い料金を払ったりせずに、大学や中小企業でも高度なエーアイを土台にできる。
工場・病院・農場・教室・街の商店まで、仕事に合ったモデルを適切なコストで使い分けられる
競争の促進。
多くの組織がエーアイを作り、改良し、提供できるため、開発者だけでなくクラウドやチップ、アプリの層でも競争が生まれ、価格が下がり、利益が広く行き渡る
主権（自分たちで技術を握り続けられること）の確保。
特定の1社に囲い込まれず、自社のデータを管理し、必要な場所でエーアイを動かせる
安全性についての論点も踏み込んでいます。
オープンウェイトには、いったん公開すると開発元の管理を離れ、改変版を追跡しにくいという固有のリスクがある。
しかし書簡は「だから禁止する」のは正しい対応ではないとします。
サイバー攻撃を仕掛ける側が高度なエーアイを使う時代には、守る側にも同等の能力を持つモデルが必要であり、公開されていれば多くの研究者が挙動を検証し、弱点を見つけて修正できるからです。
少数の非公開モデルに能力を集中させることこそ「そこが壊れると全体が止まる単一障害点」を生む、むしろ透明性の高さが安全につながる、という逆転の発想です。
あわせて、政策立案者には、スタートアップや研究者への計算資源の開放、共有データセットや評価の仕組みへの投資、そして蒸留（distillation。
あるモデルの出力を使って別のモデルを訓練・改良するいっぱん的な手法）を不正な盗用と混同して過度に規制しないことを求めています。
[EN]この書簡には、NVIDIAだけでなく、Google、Microsoft、OpenAI、Meta、AMD、IBM、Cisco、Palantir、Hugging Face、Mistral、Cohere、The Linux Foundation、Y Combinator、Andreessen Horowitzなど、通常はしのぎを削るライバル同士を含む数十社が名を連ねています。
[/EN]
オープンウェイトなエーアイモデルの重要性に関する書簡が、エヌビディア、Palantir、メタだけでなく、グーグル、マイクロソフト、そして オープンエーアイ からも出た点はとても重要です。
少し前に、エヌビディアとPalantirが、米国政府機関向けのオープンウェイトなエーアイモデルの活用についての提携を発表しましたが、その延長上にある話です。
このメルマガにも、しばしば、オープンウェイトなエーアイモデルを使うべきかどうか、という質問が来ます。
「機密保持やコストを考慮しながら使い分けるべき」というのが私の回答ですが、オープンウェイトなモデルの性能がクローズドなものに迫りつつあることは事実だし、こんな風に業界全体でオープンウェイトなモデルを推進する動きが進めば環境も整ってくると思います。
アンソロピックが参加していない理由は明らかにされていません。
同社はオープンモデルの全面禁止には反対しているものの、安全保障上のリスクについては他社より慎重な立場を取っており、その温度差が表れた可能性があります。
逆に、クローズドなモデルでビジネスをしているオープンエーアイが参加していることの方が意外ですが、オープンエーアイは、gpt-oss というオープンウェイトなエーアイモデルも公開しているので、この段階でこの書簡を支援しておくことが政治的に重要と判断したのでしょう。
エーアイ革命がスマホ向けメモリ（LPDDR5X）に与える影響
ジーピーユーに注目が集まるいっぽうで、メモリしじょうでも大きな変化が起きています。
まず、Micronとメタは共同ホワイトペーパーで、スマートフォン向けに開発された省電力メモリ「LPDDR5X」を、エーアイデータセンターの標準メモリとして使うべきだと提案しています。
LPDDR5Xは、パソコンやサーバーで使われる従来のメモリ（DDR5）よりしょうひ電力が大幅に低く、新しいモジュール規格「SOCAMM2」（メモリを基板に差し込む形で搭載するための規格）の採用により、交換性や大容量化といったデータセンターの要求も満たせるようになりました。
もはやLPDDR5Xはモバイル向け部品ではなく、エーアイインフラを支える重要な技術になりつつあります。
その影響を最も受けているのがアップルです。
これまでアップルは巨額の前払い契約でメモリしじょうの価格決定権を握ってきました。
しかしエーアイサーバー向けじゅようが急増した結果、エヌビディアなどのエーアイ企業がアップルを上回るきぼでLPDDR5Xを買い集めるようになり、アップルは価格交渉力を失いつつあります。
記事では、その結果としてアップルはMacなどの値上げを余儀なくされたと分析しています。
さらに、その余波は米中対立にも及んでいます。
アップルは中国製メモリの利用を認めるよう米政府に働きかけていますが、Micronは「メモリはジーピーユーと同じ戦略技術であり、中国メーカーを育てるべきではない」と強く反発しています。
エーアイによってじゅようが急増したことで、メモリは単なる部品ではなく、安全保障上も重要な技術と見なされ始めたのです。
エヌビディアのジーピーユーとアップルのMシリーズのチップは、一つのパッケージの中に計算を行うチップとメモリチップの両方を搭載する形状になっていることはいぜんから知っていましたが、ジーピーユーは転送スピードを重視したHBM、Mシリーズの方はしょうひ電力を重視したLPDDR5Xと、異なる種類のメモリが使われていたため、二社の間にメモリの争奪戦は起こらなかったのです。
しかし、低しょうひ電力であることがエーアイデータセンターにおいても重要なことが明らかになるにつれ、エヌビディアもLPDDR5Xを大量に購入するようになり、結果として、アップルはLPDDR5Xの最大の顧客ではなくなってしまったのです。
【参考資料】
[EN]LPDDR for General-Purpose and AI Workloads in Large-Scale Data Center Deployments[/EN]
[EN]Apple Is Facing A Shift It Never Encountered In Its Two-Decade History[/EN]
アップル vs. Micron: メモリをめぐる米中攻防
私の目に留まった記事
[EN]Broadcom's Charlie Kawwas: How Custom Silicon Is Rewriting the AI Chip Wars[/EN]
Broadcom（ブロードコム）の半導体部門トップ、チャーリー・カワス氏へのインタビュー記事で、エーアイの世界で王者エヌビディアのジーピーユーに対抗する「カスタムシリコン」がなぜ急拡大しているのかを解説する記事です。
まず驚くのが数字です。
5年前はほぼゼロだったBroadcomのカスタムエーアイチップ事業は急成長し、同社は2027年に年間売上1000億ドル超を目指しています。
カワス氏はこれをファッションにたとえます。
エヌビディアのジーピーユーは「誰にでも合う既製服」であり、Broadcomが手がけるのは、巨大エーアイ企業一社一社のために仕立てる「オートクチュール」のチップだ、というのです。
なぜわざわざ注文服なのか。
カワス氏は、汎用のジーピーユーには二つの「税金」が乗っていると指摘します。
一つは「効率の税」で、みんな向けに作られたチップは、どの会社にとっても最適ではなく、使わない機能の分まで料金を払わされます。
もう一つが「マージンの税」です。
エヌビディアの粗利益率は7〜8割で、その上乗せ分はそのまま買い手の負担になります。
エーアイ企業1社が年間$150〜200billion（約23〜30兆円）を投じる時代には、この上乗せは1社あたり$100〜150billion（約15〜23兆円）分の「本来なら買えたはずの計算能力」を失うのに等しい、というのがカワス氏の主張です。
この専用チップは進化も速く、メモリーも計算能力も毎年およそ3倍になり、（別の指標である）面積あたりのシリコンの密度も2年で16倍に高まり、最大構成のパッケージは社内で「ビースト（怪物）」と呼ばれています。
しかもレゴのように部品を組み替えるモジュールせっけいのおかげで、ある新型チップはわずか9か月で完成しました。
カワス氏が「エーアイインフラ投資の約9割を占める」と呼ぶ「ビッグ5」（オープンエーアイ、アンソロピック、グーグル、メタ、xAI）のうち4社が、Broadcomのカスタムチップを採用または契約済みだといいます。
じゅようはもはや個数ではなくしょうひ電力の「ギガワット（発電・しょうひ電力の単位）」で語られ、ある1社だけでもことし1.5ギガワット、らいねん6.5ギガワット、3年目には10ギガワット超へと膨らむ見通しです。
いっぽうで、最大の機会がそのまま最大のリスクにもなっています。
カワス氏いわく「この注文服の工房は、心地よくさばける以上の注文を抱えている」。
ボトルネックはもはやじゅようではなく、チップの材料であるウエハー（半導体を作る円盤状の薄い板）、メモリー、そして電力という物理的な供給力であり、Broadcomは最大級のパッケージ向けに専用工場をシンガポールに建設中だとしています。
私がBroadcomの株の保有を始めたのは2年ほど前なので、エヌビディアほどの値上がりは経験していませんが、今のところ順調なので、このまま長期保有をするつもりです。
ちなみに、下は、過去2年間の両社(AVGOはBroadcomのティッカー・シンボル)の株価の推移を、起点を100としてグラフにしたものです。
純利益の方をグラフにすると、以下のようになります。
数字だけ見ると、エヌビディアの方が魅力的に見えますが、Broadcomの方が株価の伸びが良いのは、少なくとも、この期間の株価には、現在の利益だけでなく、カスタムエーアイチップの将来成長が強く織り込まれているからだと解釈して良いと思います。
[EN]OpenAI CEO Sam Altman admits company lagged behind Anthropic’s Claude Code[/EN]
ことしになって、アンソロピックの売り上げがオープンエーアイを超えたことが大きな話題になっていますが、その原因を作ったClaude Code（アンソロピック製のエーアイコーディングツール）に関して、オープンエーアイのシーイーオー、Sam Altmanが、「出遅れた」ことを正直に認める発言をしたことを紹介する記事です。
この記事によると、オープンエーアイは、コーディングツールであるCodexは2021年という早い段階からリリースしていたものの、ChatGPTの成功いらい、様々なことに手を出した結果、Claude Codeへの一点集中で勝負を賭けてきたアンソロピックに大きく水を開けられてしまったのです。
オープンエーアイは、去年、（コーディングツールを提供している）Windsurfの買収により乗り切ろうとしましたが、マイクロソフトがオープンエーアイの持つ知的財産の全てにアクセスできるという契約を交わしていたことが仇になり、買収を断念せざるを得なくなってしまいました。
Windsurfが持つ知的所有権だけは、その契約対象からオープンエーアイが外そうとしたものの、マイクロソフトがそれに同意をしなかったからだと解釈されています。
オープンエーアイはその後、Codexの開発に力を入れて、使い勝手でもかなりClaude Codeに迫るところにまで来たようですが、一度作られてしまったClaude Codeの勢いを止めることができていません（私自身は、もっぱらClaude Codeを使っています）。
[EN]Apple Glasses May Debut at WWDC 2027: Privacy, Camera Features Versus Meta[/EN]
アップルが開発中のスマートグラスを2027年6月のWWDC（アップルが毎年開く開発者向けの発表会）で公開する計画で、その最大の売りは「プライバシー保護」になる、というBloombergのMark Gurman氏によるレポートです。
先行するメタがカメラ付きメガネで何につまずいたのかが見えてくる記事なので紹介します。
社内でN50というコードネームで呼ばれているこの製品は、2027年6月に発表し、同年末に出荷という段取りだと報じられています。
当初は2026年中の発表を目指していたものの、プライバシー戦略を練り直すために後ろ倒しになったとのことです。
メタの「Ray-Ban メタ」と同様に、スピーカーとマイクを内蔵し、音楽再生・通話・Siriとの対話をメガネだけでこなせるものになります。
社内で意見が割れているのが「カメラを載せるかどうか」です。
検討されている案は主に2つで、ひとつはカメラは載せるが写真・動画の撮影機能は完全に殺し、映像はSiriが周囲を認識するため（Visual Intelligence）だけに使うというもの。
もうひとつは、カメラそのものを取り去り、ハンズフリーのSiri・音楽・通話に絞るというものです。
最終的にはカメラを載せた上で、強力なプライバシー保護の仕組みを付ける形に落ち着く可能性が高いと見られています。
背景にあるのが、メタがはまった落とし穴です。
Ray-Ban メタは700万台以上を売ったいっぽうで、エーアイの学習用データを整えるためにケニアの委託作業者が、利用者の知らないうちに撮影された私的な映像を目にしていたと報じられ、集団訴訟にまで発展しました。
「プライバシーを守る会社」という評判を長年かけて築いてきたアップルにとって、メタと同じような失敗をするわけには絶対にいかないので、必要以上に慎重になっているのは当然だと思います。
私は、メタのスマートグラスを持っていて、時々使っていますが（TeslaのFSDの様子を撮影するのに最適です）、まだ「毎日の生活になくてはならないデバイス」にはなっていません。
アップルからスマートグラスが発売されたらすぐに入手する予定ですが、一番の価値はデバイスではなく、エーアイアシスタントにあるので、そこをどう作ってくるかが楽しみです。
少し前に触れたように、私自身が開発しているMulmoClaudeは「エーアイアシスタントを自分のパソコンで育てる場」として提供しており、現時点ではスマートフォンからのリモートアクセスを可能にしています。
こんご、各社からスマートグラスが発売され、よりオープンな形でアプリなどを作れるようになった時には、MulmoClaude向けのリモートアクセス・アプリを作るのも悪くないと考えています。
その場合、アップルやメタ自身が提供してくるエーアイアシスタントとの関係がどうなるかは不明ですが、彼らも完全にクローズにすることはないだろうと期待しています。
[EN]Nvidia in talks with OpenAI to guarantee $250 billion financing for data center[/EN]
半導体メーカーのNvidiaが、オープンエーアイの巨大データセンター向けに二千五百億ドル（約37兆円）もの資金調達を保証しようとしている、という報道です。
エーアイ業界の「お金の回し方」がどんどん複雑になっていることを示す象徴的な話なので、紹介します。
このデータセンターは、SoftBankのエネルギー子会社が米国オハイオ州南部に建設中の、電力規模10ギガワットという超巨大プロジェクトです。
第一段階として、2028年までに800メガワット分を稼働させる計画です。
プロジェクト全体のコストは、中に入れるNvidia製のチップも含めると五千億ドル（約74兆円）を超えると見られています。
Nvidiaが保証しようとしている二千五百億ドルは、このうちデータセンターの賃借料と借入金にあたる部分で、中に入れるチップ代は含みません。
そのチップ代については、別途、オープンエーアイが最大三千五百億ドル（約52兆円）分を購入するための資金を、これもNvidiaが支援する形で話が進んでいるとされています。
オープンエーアイにとって、この取引はマイクロソフト、アマゾン、オラクルといった他社からデータセンターを「借りる」立場から、自前の設備を「持つ」立場へと移る第一歩になります。
いっぽう、Nvidiaにとっては、自社のチップのじゅようがなんねんも先まで保証されることになります。
ただし、チップを売る会社が、そのチップを買う会社に資金まで用意するという構図には、「Nvidiaがオープンエーアイに出したお金が、チップ購入という形でNvidiaに戻ってくるだけではないか」という、いわゆる「お金がぐるぐる回っているだけ」という指摘も出ています。
この件は、日本政府が関税引き下げと引き換えに約束した五千五百億ドルの対米投資と、深く関わっています。
このデータセンターの敷地内に設置される火力発電所の費用**三百三十二億九千九百九十九万九千九百九十九ドル（約5兆円）は、日本が公的資金（債務保証を含む）を使って提供します**。
つまり、事業リスクは日本側が負担します。
しかも、その事業が生み出すキャッシュフローは、日本が「投資額」を回収するまでは50:50、回収後は米国90:日本10という、米国側に有利な条件で分けられます（
日米政府の戦略的投資イニシアティブの第一陣プロジェクトについて
このガス火力は、五千五百億ドル枠の「第一陣」3案件のうち、最大のものです。
建設地は旧ウラン濃縮工場の跡地、つまり米エネルギー省が所有する連邦有地であり、どの案件に日本の資金を充てるかを選定する米国投資委員会の議長は、Lutnick商務長官です。
日本側に、投資先を選ぶ権限はありません。
そう考えると、この話には二重の円環があることが見えてきます。
内側にあるのが、Nvidiaが出した金がチップ代としてNvidiaに戻ってくる円環。
外側にあるのが、日本が公的資金でその土台となる電源を用意し、生み出された利益の9割が米国に渡っていく円環です。
そして日本がこれをやっている理由は、エーアイインフラに投資したいからではありません。
自動車をはじめとする輸出品のかんぜいを15パーセントに抑えてもらうためです。
日本の公的支援がどの条件で発動し、どこまで損失を負担するのかは、納税者の立場から厳しく検証すべきです。
[EN]Cognition & Scott Wu: The Golden Age[/EN]
人間の代わりにプログラムを書くエーアイエンジニア、DevinをかいはつしたCognition社の創業者スコット・ウー氏が、「エーアイはエンジニアの仕事を奪うのではなく、ソフトウェアエンジニアリングの黄金時代を開く」と語った講演を紹介する記事です。
ウー氏はまず「もし無限の数のソフトウェアエンジニアが手に入ったら、あなたは何を作りますか？
」と問いかけます。
世間ではエーアイがエンジニアの職を奪うという不安が広がっていますが、彼の主張はその正反対で、生産性が爆発的に上がることで、むしろ作るべきものが増えていく、というものです。
その根拠として彼が示すのが、自分たちの会社で実際に起きた変化です。
この半年（さくねん11月からことし4月）で、Cognitionが世に出したソフトウェアの量はおよそ10倍に増えましたが、エンジニアの人数は45人から60人へと4割ほどしか増えていません。
いまや同社でコミットされるコードの9割以上を書いているのは人間ではなくDevinで、しかもその多くは、性能の劣化・エラー・顧客からの問い合わせといった「きっかけ」を検知して、Devinが自分から動き出したものだといいます。
なぜ今それが可能になったのか。
ウー氏は、エーアイが一度に任される仕事の長さが急激に伸びたことを挙げます。
研究機関METRの調査では、エーアイがこなせる作業時間は、ジーピーティー-3.5の頃の約30秒から、いまや16時間、さらには数日がかりの課題へと跳ね上がりました。
「数日かける仕事を任せられるなら、それはもう単なるアシスタントではなく一人前の同僚だ」というのが彼の見立てです。
その結果、会社の回り方そのものが「人が仕事を始める」から「出来事が仕事を引き起こす」へと変わり、セキュリティ警告が出ればDevinが自動で直し、大規模な書き換えはファイルごとに並列で走り、バグ報告はそのままDevinに流れて修正案となって戻ってくる、という形になっているそうです。
いっぽうでウー氏は、だいじな注意も添えます。
それは「間違ったものを測るな」ということ。
彼が戒めるのは「トークン・マキシング」（エーアイが消費したトークン＝処理量そのものを成果として競ってしまうこと）で、これは昔の「書いたコードの行数」という古い評価基準と同じ過ちだといいます。
そして彼は本当の課題を突きつけます。
モデルが動くかどうかは、もう問題ではない。
本当の問いは、何万人ものエンジニアと染みついた仕事のやり方を抱えた巨大企業──Goldman Sachs（ゴールドマン・サックス）、Mercedes-Benz、Lowe's（ロウズ。
米国のホームセンター大手）──が、どれだけ速く自らをエーアイ中心に組み替えられるか、なのだと。
私もさいきんは、もっぱらエーアイ（Claude Code）にコードを書かせるスタイルに変わりましたが、結果として、これまで「コードを書くこと」に費やしていた時間を「どんな機能を追加するか」「どんなユーザー体験を提供すべきか」に時間を割けるようになったのは大きな成果です。
特にさいきんは、エーアイがコードを書くスピードが上がったので、私がボトルネックになっているとつくづく感じます。
「コードはエーアイに書かせながら、その間にメルマガの執筆をする」などがじょうずにできれば良いのですが、それが結構難しく、現時点ではそれが一番の悩みです。
[EN]Think That Party Invite Is Real? Fake E-Vite Scams Are the New Phishing Trap[/EN]
パーティの招待状を装ったフィッシング詐欺が横行しているという記事です。
実は、私の妻のメアドに彼女の知り合いから招待状が来て、彼女が招待状を開けようとしたら開かないと相談されたので、確認したところ、EXEファイル（Windows向けのアプリ）がダウンロードされており、彼女のマシンがMacBookだったので、たまたま実行できずに助かった、という状況でした。
送られて来たメールを見ると、実際に彼女の知り合いのメアドから送られており、招待状のデザインも非常に洗練されているため、私でも開いてしまった可能性が高いと感じました。
このフィッシング詐欺が巧みなのは、一旦マシンを乗っ取ると、そこからその人のメアドで招待状が送れてしまう点で、それゆえ、彼女のように招待状を開こうとしてしまう人が大勢いるのです。
[EN]AI is igniting a love affair between Silicon Valley and the consulting industry[/EN]
シリコンバレーのエーアイ企業と、McKinsey・Accenture・BCGといった大手コンサルティング会社が、かつてないほど急接近している、という記事です。
両者がなぜ手を組むのか、その理由がよくわかるので紹介します。
エーアイをかいはつする企業にとって最大の悩みは、優れたモデルを作っても、それを大企業に売り込み、実際の業務に組み込んでもらうのが難しいことです。
そこで頼りになるのが、長年かけて大企業の経営陣とのパイプを築いてきたコンサルティング会社です。
いっぽうのコンサル側も、エーアイによって自分たちの仕事のやり方が大きく変わりつつあり、エーアイ企業と組まなければ時代遅れになるという危機感を抱えています。
つまり、お互いに相手を必要としている関係なのです。
具体的な動きも次々と出ています。
グーグルは、McKinsey・Accenture・Deloitteといった会社が「エージェント型エーアイ（人の代わりに複数の作業を自律的にこなすエーアイ）」を企業に導入するのを後押しするため、七億五千万ドル（約1,100億円）の基金を立ち上げました。
オープンエーアイも、エーアイプログラミング支援ツール「Codex」を広めるために、Accenture・Capgemini・PwCと組んでいます。
McKinseyに至っては、ChatGPTの登場以降、技術パートナーの数を4倍に増やしたといいます。
この変化は、コンサル会社の売上構成にもはっきり表れています。
McKinseyは、いまや仕事の約40パーセントが生成エーアイ関連であり、BCGも2024年の仕事の20パーセントがエーアイ絡みだったと報告しています。
パートナーを組むスピードも変わりました。
ChatGPT登場前は、売上千万ドル以上に育ったエーアイ企業としか組まなかったのが、今では売上$2〜5million、創業12〜18ヶ月ほどの若い会社とも手を組むようになっています。
McKinseyのシニアパートナー、Ben Ellencweig氏は「パートナーシップとは双方向の関係だ」と語り、小さな会社とも積極的に協業する姿勢を示しています。
この話は、エーアイをネタにビジネスをしようと考えている人たちにとってはとても参考になる話です。
エーアイが社会を大きく変えることは明らかですが、ChatGPTができることは限られているし、Claude Codeのようなものを利用できる人たちもごくいちぶです。
企業がエーアイをビジネスに活用する手伝いをするコンサルタント・ビジネスが必要とされているのはそれが理由で、McKinseyやAccentureは、そこにある種の「特需」を見ているのです。
エーアイがさらに進化すれば不要になりそうな気もしますが、少なくとも今の時点では良いビジネス・チャンスと言えます。
[EN]Tesla FSD helps senior drivers keep their independence[/EN]
Teslaの運転支援システム「FSD（Full Self-Driving＝監視付きの自動運転支援機能）」が、高齢のドライバーが車の運転を続ける助けになっている、というThe Detroit Newsの記事です。
年を取ると、反射神経や視力が自然に衰えていきますが、車での移動の自由をあきらめたくない高齢者たちが、FSDを「もう一つの目」として使い始めています。
92歳のLeonard Krausさんは、走行距離の87パーセントをFSDで運転し、95歳の義理の兄にもすすめたそうです。
「これがなかったら、私はもう運転していないと思う」と語っています。
元General Motorsのエンジニアで78歳のDick Amacherさんは、Model YとModel 3の運転の98パーセントをFSDにまかせています。
「私と同じくらい運転がうまい」と言い、その理由をこう説明します。
「赤信号は絶対に無視しないし、一時停止の標識も必ず守る。
木の枝で半分隠れた標識があるような住宅街でも、私より先に標識を見つけてくれる」。
さらにAmacherさんは、こんな体験も語っています。
デトロイトに向かって高速道路を降りたとき、車が突然、道路の端に寄って止まったそうです。
「何が起きたんだと思った」。
理由は、後ろから緊急車両が近づいていたこと。
FSDは、人間より先にそれを緊急車両だと認識していたのです。
「車はあらゆる方向を同時に見ている。
人間には真似できない」。
私もつい先日、片道100キロほどのドライブをしましたが、家から目的地まで100パーセントハンズフリーで安全に到着しました。
これだけは、実際に経験しないと分かりませんが、ストレスがないので、全く疲れませんでした。
[EN]Personal Superintelligence for Everyone[/EN]
メタのマーク・ザッカーバーグシーイーオーが公開した、「超知能（人間の知能を超えたエーアイ）は、いちぶの企業や政府が独占するのではなく、一人ひとりの手に渡すべきだ」と主張する公開レターです。
彼が最近WSJに寄稿した同じ趣旨のオピニオン記事は有料の壁の内側にありますが、こちらはメタ公式サイトで誰でも全文を読めます。
ザッカーバーグはまず、「エーアイが自分自身を少しずつ賢くしていく」兆しがすでに見えており、超知能の実現が視野に入ってきた、と語ります。
その上で、この強力な技術をどう扱うかについて、業界には二つの異なる考え方があると整理します。
一つは、超知能を中央に集めて価値ある仕事をすべて自動化させ、人間はその成果を分け与えられて（ベーシックインカムのような形で）暮らす、という発想です。
もう一つが、彼自身が目指す「パーソナル超知能」です。
一人ひとりが、自分の目標や価値観、置かれた状況をよく理解してくれる専用のエーアイを持ち、それを使って作りたいものを作り、なりたい自分に近づいていく。
目的は人間の仕事を機械に置き換えることではなく、個人が自分の人生を自分の望む方向に進める力を高めることだ、というのが彼の主張の中心です。
こうしたエーアイは、スマートグラスのように一日中そばにある身近な機器を通じて使えるようになる、とも述べています。
その実現手段として彼が重視するのが、オープンソースです。
メタが技術を進歩させれば、その恩恵がメタだけでなく世界中の人に行き渡る、という考え方です。
ただしザッカーバーグ自身も、超知能が新しい安全上の懸念を生むことは認めており、何を公開するかは慎重に選ぶとしています。
それでもレター全体を貫くのは、「エーアイの力を怖がって少数の手に囲い込むのではなく、できるだけ多くの人に開いていくことこそが良い未来につながる」というメッセージです。
呼び方は違いますが、「パーソナル超知能」とはまさに、私が開発しているMulmoClaudeが作るのを目指す「自分だけのエーアイアシスタント」です。
エーアイモデルがいくら賢くなったとしても、最終的には「どのくらい自分のことを理解してくれているか」が鍵を握ります。
その際には、エーアイモデルそのものがオープン・ウェイトかどうかよりも、エーアイモデルの周りに蓄積される自分に関する情報がどこに蓄積されて誰がコントロールするかが何よりも大切だと私は考えます。
上の文章を読む限り、ザッカーバーグは、エーアイモデルはオープンにしつつ、ユーザーに関する情報はメタがFacebookやInstagramなどのサービスを通じて握る戦略に出ているように私には思えます。
[EN]The Next AI Moat Isn't a Better Model[/EN]
自動運転車やロボットのような「物理的なエーアイ」で本当の競争力になるのは、賢いモデルそのものではなく、そのモデルを素早く現場で使えるようにする仕組みだ、と主張する記事です。
著者のPeter Ludwigは、多くの人が「モデルが賢くなれば、そのまま良い自動運転車やロボットができる」と思い込んでいる、と指摘します。
しかし現実には、優れたモデルが手に入っても、それを実際の車やロボットに組み込み、あらゆる状況でテストし、安全性の認証を取り、現場で検証するまでに何ヶ月もかかります。
つまり、性能を決めているのはモデルの賢さではなく、その周りにある「開発から実用化までの流れ（パイプライン）」であり、この流れがこの10年ほとんど進化していない、というのです。
ここで重要なのが、文章やプログラムを扱うデジタル世界のエーアイエージェントは、物理世界の仕事にはそのまま使えない、という点です。
物理的なエーアイが相手にするのは、走行ログ、センサーのデータ、シミュレーションの結果、車両群から送られてくる大量の情報であり、文書やコードではありません。
「安全性が確認できた」とはどういう状態を指すのか、こうした判断は、その分野を深く理解した専用のエージェントでなければできない、と著者は言います。
そして著者は、速さこそが安全性を高める、という一見意外な主張をします。
テストの結果が数週間ではなく数分で返ってくるようになれば、その分だけ多くの状況を試し、問題を早く見つけられます。
実際、著者が関わるApplied IntuitionのDanaというプラットフォームでは、かいはつのサイクルが約20倍速くなり、現場への反映も「数週間に一度」から「一日になんども」に変わったとしています。
現場のデータが次のテストやモデル改良につながり、それがまたエージェントを賢く・速くする――この循環が回るほど、賢さと速さの両方が積み重なっていく。
「知能はどこにでも手に入るようになった。
それを実際に使えるようにする力は、まだそうではない」という一文が、記事の主張を言い表しています。
さいきんの特徴は、この手の「エーアイモデル以外」の議論が盛んになったことで、これは、徐々に「生のエーアイモデル」に何ができて、何ができないのか、が徐々に明らかになってきた結果だと私は思います。
私のように、「エーアイモデル以外」の部分で価値を作りだそうと考えるエンジニアが増えているのも、とても良い傾向だと思います。
[EN]Market Chatter: Alphabet's Google DeepMind Disbands AlphaFold Team[/EN]
グーグルが、ノーベル賞を受賞したエーアイ「AlphaFold」の専任チームを解散させ、研究者たちを主力エーアイ「Gemini」の開発に振り分けた、という報道です。
エーアイかいはつの主戦場が、特定の課題に特化したエーアイから、汎用的なエーアイへと移っていることを象徴する動きです。
AlphaFoldは、グーグル傘下のDeepMindがかいはつした、タンパク質の立体構造を予測するエーアイです。
タンパク質は、体の中でさまざまな働きをする部品のようなもので、その形が分かると、病気の仕組みの解明や新しい薬のかいはつが大きく前進します。
この成果によって、DeepMindのデミス・ハサビス氏らは2024年のノーベル化学賞を受賞しました。
その快挙をあげたチームが、今回、解散となりました。
多くの研究者は、Geminiというエルエルエム（大規模言語モデル。
大量の文章を学習して人間のように受け答えするエーアイ）を使った開発へと配置転換され、残りは酵素の設計、核融合、ゲノム研究、そしてAlphaFoldの技術を創薬に応用するAlphabet傘下のIsomorphic Labsなどに移りました。
DeepMindは、これを「Geminiを土台にして、科学者を助けたり研究作業のいちぶを自動化したりするシステムを作る、という大きな戦略の一環」と説明しています。
Isomorphic Labsという子会社も作ったし、オープンエーアイやアンソロピックといったライバルとの競争も激化しているので、当然の動きだと思います。
世界最高峰の研究者を抱えながら、エルエルエムのビジネスに関しては「三番手」に甘んじている状況を、そろそろ脱したいところです。
[EN]Optimizing the Frontier Performance Curve[/EN]
マイクロソフトが、エーアイを「とにかく大きなモデルを使えばいい」という発想から、「かかる費用に対してどれだけの性能が出るか」を重視する方向へと舵を切ったことを説明する記事です。
同社のエーアイ部門トップであるMustafa Suleyman氏が、なぜ巨大な一つのモデルに頼らないのかを解説しています。
これまでエーアイ業界では、"tokenmaxxing"（トークンマクシング。
とにかく大量の計算を注ぎ込んで、より大きく賢いモデルを作ろうとする考え方）が主流でした。
しかしマイクロソフトは、これを見直し、「一番難しい仕事にだけ高価で高性能なモデルを使い、それ以外の日常的な仕事には、小さくて速い専用モデルを使う」という仕組みに切り替えています。
モデル本体だけでなく、それを動かす仕組みや学習環境までまとめて最適化することで、性能とコストのバランスが最も良い点を狙うという考え方です。
その具体例として、同社が"Flash"と名付けた一連の軽量モデルの成果が紹介されています。
たとえばセキュリティ用の"MAI-Cyber-1-Flash"は、CyberGymというベンチマークで首位に立ち、競合を12ポイント上回りながらコストを半分に抑えました。
90パーセントの仕事はこの軽量モデルでこなし、本当に難しい残り10パーセントだけをジーピーティー-5.4に任せる、という使い分けをしています。
他にも、GitHub CopilotやVS Codeに6月から組み込まれている"MAI-Code-1-Flash"は、コードの受け入れ率を10パーセント高めつつ、使うトークン量を10パーセント減らしました。
プレゼン資料作成に使われる画像モデル"MAI-Image-2.5-Flash"は、PowerPointでのジーピーユーコストを最大84パーセント削減。
音声モデル"MAI-Voice-2-Flash"はT-MobileやEasyJetのコールセンターで使われ、ジーピーユーコストを最大89パーセント下げています。
医療現場向けの文字起こしモデル"MAI-Transcribe-1.5"は58言語に対応し、17万人の医療従事者が使う文字起こしの誤りを半減させました。
オープンエーアイの大株主でもあるマイクロソフトが、こんな動きに出ているのは、マイクロソフトが、単に「エーアイサービスを売る」のでなく、「顧客がエーアイを業務に効率よく取り入れる」ことを支援することに力を入れていることを示し、私は高く評価します。
さらにこんごの動きとして、パソコン上で動くエーアイモデルもサポートすることになれば、さらに価値が高まると思います。
[EN]Pacing the Frontier[/EN]
エーアイをかいはつする企業で働く1,273人の従業員が、「エーアイの進化のスピードを、意図的に緩めるための仕組みを作ろう」と各国政府に呼びかける共同声明を発表した、という記事です。
かいはつの当事者たち自身が「速すぎる」と声を上げた点で注目に値します。
この声明の背景にあるのは、エーアイの進化があまりに速いという危機感です。
署名者たちは「わずか4年間で、エーアイは言葉を理解する段階から、ソフトウェアかいはつの分野で人間を上回る段階にまで進んだ」と指摘しています。
さらに、エーアイ自身がエーアイの研究かいはつを行う「自動エーアイ研究」が現実味を帯びており、そうなると進化のスピードはさらに加速すると警告しています。
彼らが最も問題視しているのは、「一社や一国だけでは、かいはつのスピードを緩められない」という構造です。
ライバルに先を越されることを恐れるあまり、各企業・各国は競争から降りられず、安全対策が進化のスピードに追いつかないまま突き進んでしまう。
具体的なリスクとしては、「エーアイエージェントが、実際に使われているソフトウェアの弱点を見つけて悪用できてしまう」といったサイバー攻撃の危険を挙げています。
そこでこの声明が求めているのが、「ペース調整」、つまりエーアイが人間の理解や制御を追い越さないよう、進化のスピードを意図的に緩めるための国際的な枠組みづくりです。
具体的には、米国政府が主導して、フロンティアモデル(最先端の大規模エーアイ)のリリースを各国で監視する仕組みや、かいはつの進み具合を検証し合う技術的・統治的なツールを国際協調のもとで整備することを提案しています。
「かいはつを止めろ」ではなく、社会が追いつくための時間を稼ぐ、という発想です。
署名者には、アンソロピック シーイーオーのDario Amodei氏、オープンエーアイの主席科学者（チーフサイエンティスト）Jakub Pachocki氏、グーグル DeepMind共同創設者のShane Legg氏など、業界を代表する顔ぶれが並びます。
運営を支えているのは、Guidelight エーアイ StandardsやEncode エーアイといった独立系の非営利団体です。
アンソロピック、オープンエーアイ、グーグルという競合三社の幹部が揃って名を連ねるのは珍しいことですが、政府主導で規制機関が作られてしまうのを避けるために一歩先に独立系の業界団体を作ろうというアイデアは、先日紹介した
[EN]Demis Hassabisの提案[/EN]
を発展させたものと考えて良いと思います。
質問コーナー
【質問】
MulmoClaudeについての質問です。
データソースフィードに登録したサイトを統合して一覧で見れるアプリ(News Feed Hub)をコレクションに作成しました。
データソースフィードは今はURLを追加していくだけですが、フィード内でアプリを作れれば良いかなと思ったのですが実装予定などありますでしょうか？
今、自宅のMac miniをホストにしているのですが、外出先でも使いたいと思っています、VPNやリモートデスクトップではなく、直接MulmoClaudeにアクセスして触りたいと考えていますが、そのような実装予定はありますでしょうか？
MulmoClaudeはClaudeのどのモデルを使っているのでしょうか？
推論effortで、(Claudeのデフォルトの使用)とありましたが、Claude Codeのデフォルトのモデルを使用しているという事でしょうか？
《回答》
「アプリ」の定義にもよりますが、custom view と複数のコレクションの連携で、かなりのことができると思います。
まずは「何をやりたいのか」を頭の中で明確にした上で、エルエルエムに依頼してみてください。
外出先からパソコン上のMulmoClaudeにアクセスする機能は順次追加しているので、具体的なリクエストを github issue にいただけると幸いです。
MulmoClaudeをスマホ上で動かしたり、ウェブ上のサービスとして提供する予定は現時点ではありません。
Claude Codeのデフォルトのモデルを使用しています。
推論effortの方は、設定画面から選択が可能です。
【質問】
「デミス・ハサビスやジェンセン・ファンといったトップ識者が『2026年にAGIが実現する（あるいは実現した）』と述べており、シンギュラリティへの肉薄を感じさせます。
本当にAGIは実現したと言えるのでしょうか？
また、仮に実現した場合、こんごの世界はどう変化し、米国と中国のエーアイ競争はどのような展開を迎えると考えられますか？
」
《回答》
AGIの定義そのものが曖昧なので、「AGIが実現したかどうか」の議論にはあまり意味がありません。
「激辛ラーメン」の「激辛」の定義が曖昧なのと同様です。
少し前に書きましたが、既に数学オリンピックにおいては、人類の最高峰クラスに達しており、数学やコーディングのように「答えが正しいか正しくないか」が明確に判断できる問題に関しては、平均的な人間をはるかに凌駕しており、その意味では十分に「激辛」です（笑）。
「ホワイトカラーの8割の仕事はエーアイにさせた方が安く・早く・正確」な時代が間もなく来る（1〜2年以内）ことは明確です。
とはいえ、それを社会が受け入れ、十分に活用するには時間がかかります。
生産性の向上、科学の進歩の加速、低コスト化などの良い面と、失業、貧富の差、既存のキャリアパスの消失、などの悪い面の両方が起こるため、政治家が国をよほどじょうずに運営しない限り、大きな痛み・混乱が生じ、社会が不安定になる（極右・極左の台頭、戦争など）可能性が大きいのが心配です。
米中の関係がどうなるかを予想するのは簡単ではありませんが、何らかの「分断」（主に輸出・輸入規制の加速による経済圏の分断）が起こることは避けられないと思います。
素材・部品のサプライチェーンを中国に握られてしまっている点が、米国（＝西側）の最大の弱点で、さらに最先端の半導体の生産が台湾でしかできていない点が、大きな懸念です。
この弱点・懸念に関しては、「予測」しても意味がなく、「最悪の事態」を想定して対処・準備しておく（西側にサプライチェーンを作る）しかない、というのが私の考えです。
【質問】
エーアイ導入支援を、人月単価ではなく成果報酬型で提供したいと考えています。
エーアイ導入によって増えた利益や削減できたコストの50％を報酬として受け取るモデルです。
ただ、利益は市況や営業努力などエーアイ以外の要因でも変動します。
中島さんであれば、エーアイ導入による成果をどう切り分け、どのような指標・契約条件で成果報酬を設計しますか？
《回答》
私であれば、明確な目標（売り上げ増、利益増、不良品率の低下など）を定めた上で、その目標を達成するシステムを私が持つIP（知的財産）を使って作り（この段階では無償で働きます）、「この状態を維持したければ、これだけのライセンス料を毎年支払ってください」と要求します。
実際に数字として成果が出ており、そこに私のIPが使われているとなると、断ることはとても難しいと思います。
かなり単純化していますが、パランティアのFDEの仕事はこんなスタイルです。
【質問】
エーアイエージェント時代の投資先について、以下のような仮説を考えております。
ぜひご見解を伺いたく、ご連絡しました。
中国発の低価格なオープンウェイトエーアイ、エーダブリューエス Trainiumやグーグル ティーピーユーなどの専用ASIC、推論効率やプロンプトキャッシュの改善、小型モデル、オンプレミスエーアイへの分散、データセンターきょうきゅうの増加などにより、こんごはエーアイモデルと計算資源の低価格化・多様化が進むと考えています。
その場合、特定のエーアイモデルをかいはつする企業よりも、複数のエーアイモデルを企業業務に接続し、権限、データ、監査、コスト、セキュリティ等を管理する「エーアイコントロール層」の方が、モデル間の勝敗に左右されにくいのではないかという仮説です。
具体的には、以下の領域を想定しています。
エーアイ業務実行基盤
エーアイデータ基盤
エーアイ監視/運用基盤
エーアイ通信/エッジ基盤
エーアイセキュリティ/XDR基盤
統合サイバーセキュリティ基盤
エーアイエージェントが本番環境で動くには、モデル性能だけでなく、権限管理、承認、監査ログ、例外処理、責任所在などが不可欠です。
そのため、「エーアイを作る企業」よりも「エーアイに実際の業務を安全に実行させる場所」を持つ企業に、長期的な価値が残るのではないかと考えています。
この仮説について、大きな方向性として妥当であるか。
特に価値が集中すると考えられる領域や、見落としているリスク、この仮説が崩れる可能性についてお聞かせ下さい。
《回答》
目の付け所は悪くないと思います。
私も最終的には、オープンウェイトなモデルとクローズドなフロンティア・モデルを使い分ける形に落ち着くと考えています。
そこにさまざまなビジネス・チャンスがあることは確かで、「どのモデルに、どこまでのデータやエーピーアイをどの権限で渡すか」をコントロールするビジネスがその一つであろう、という見立ては悪くないと思います。
しかし、それがサーススタイルのビジネスになるのか、パランティアのようにFDEを送り込んで成果報酬をもらう形になるのかを予想するのは簡単ではありません。
【質問】
中島様はXevoを創業され、事業・会社を大きく成長させてこられたと理解しています。
技術バックグラウンドの創業者がBtoBの業界特化型事業を立ち上げる際には、次のような壁があるのではないかと感じています。
・そもそも事業の種（解くべき課題）を見つけること
・プロトタイプやPoCを実際に使ってくれるさいしょの顧客を見つけ、一緒にプロダクトを育ててもらうこと
・PoCやその後の営業・販売を進めること
Xevoは車載ソフトウェアという自動車業界の課題に挑戦されたと理解していますが、中島様ご自身は、これらの壁をどのように乗り越えられたのでしょうか。
また、中島様の周りにいらっしゃる技術バックグラウンドの創業者の方々は、こうした壁をどのような方法で乗り越えているのでしょうか。
私自身も技術バックグラウンドで、将来的な起業を視野に入れているため、ぜひ参考にさせていただきたく、ご質問しました。
《回答》
結構、苦労しました。
当初は、WaltDisney/ESPN向けにモバイルアプリ（iPhoneいぜんの、JavaVMが搭載された携帯電話向け）を作るビジネスで細々と食べていましたが、スクエニに買収された後に、オンデマンドテレビ向けのセットボックスの業界に踏み入れたのが良いきっかけになりました。
当時は、Androidも存在しなかったために、独自のミドルウェア(UIEngine)を使った開発効率の高さで、ビジネスを勝ち取ることができました。
これがきっかけで「組み込み機器向けのユーアイ」で勝負する覚悟ができ、デンソー経由で車載機向けのアプリを作るチャンスが到来した際に、セットボックス向けのかいはつの経験が大きな役割を果たし、後のトヨタ自動車向けの大きなビジネスに結びつけることができました。
特に功を奏したのが、セットボックスのビジネスをしていた際にライバル企業にいた人を営業のトップとして雇えたことで、その人は後に日本法人の社長として大活躍をしてくれました。
また、デンソー側で私たちの会社を「発見」してくれた人にも大いに世話になり、後にその人も私の会社に参加し、トヨタ自動車向けのビジネスで大きな貢献をしてくれました。
【質問】
集中力のコントロールについて質問です。
私は仕事や勉強において、まとまった時間、集中力を落とさずに維持するのに苦労しています。
膨大なアウトプットを出し続けていらっしゃる中島さんは、1時間やそれ以上の長時間を「ノンストップかつ高い集中状態」で維持することはできますでしょうか？
もし持続できる場合、そのためのコツや意識している心構えがあれば教えてください。
また、途中で集中を切らさないための「独自の休憩・切り替えのルール」があればぜひご教示いただきたいです。
《回答》
私の集中力にとって一番重要なことは「誰にもインタラプトされない時間」を持つことです。
その意味でも朝の4時半ぐらいに早起きして、メールもチェックせずに朝ご飯までの間に集中して働く時間は、私にとってとても貴重な時間です。
【質問】
エーアイによって実行に移せるアイデアが増えるいっぽう、数多くのプロジェクトに手を出すと「廃人」のように働かなければならなくなるため、それは避けたいとご回答いただき、ありがとうございました。
私自身の活動を見直すうえでも、大変参考になりました。
こんしゅう号で、まずエーアイに「君だったらどんな風にじっそうする？
」と尋ね、何回かのやり取りの末に仕様を固め、そこからはほとんどエーアイ任せにすると書かれていた点が印象に残りました。
そこでお伺いしたいのですが、対話を続ける段階から、ほとんどエーアイに委ねる段階へ移る際、中島様がより重視されているのは、作ってほしい完成像を十分に言葉で表現できるようになることでしょうか。
それとも、細部までは詰め切っていなくても、出来上がったものが意図どおりかをあらかじめ決めた合格基準やテストによって判定できる見通しが立てば、じっそうを委ねられるとお考えでしょうか。
《回答》
私がエーアイと共同作業でものづくりをする時に最も重視しているのは、「どんな価値を提供したいのか」「どこにこだわって作って欲しいのか」「どんなユーザー体験を提供したいのか」など、エーアイが持ち合わせない「何がたいせつなのか」を、まずは私自身にとって明確にした上で、エーアイに伝えることです。
もちろん、（Claude Codeに対する指示書である）CLAUDE.MDの中には、コンポーネントテストを作ること、タイプチェックをすること、などの当たり前のことは書いてありますが、それは当たり前のことで、唯一人間にしか提供できない価値は「何がたいせつなのか」を決めることだと思います。
【質問】
日本国内でNote株式会社様がエーアイによる効率化で営業利益を20倍に伸ばしたという報道があり、こんごはこうした事例がさらに加速すると考えています。
特にきぼの大きな企業ほど、わずかな利益率の改善が莫大なインパクトを生むはずです。
そこで質問なのですが、エーアイの導入が単なる「コスト削減」にとどまらず、ダイレクトに「利益率の向上」に直結しやすい業界やビジネスモデルには、どのような構造的な特徴があるとお考えでしょうか？
（例えば、人的リソースの配分、ビジネスの特性、扱っているデータの性質など、中島様が注目されている共通項があればぜひお聞かせください）
《回答》
記事のソースを無くしてしまいましたが、まさにこの話を書いている記事をどこかで読んだことがあります。
エーアイはこれまで非効率だった「作業」を効率化するのがとくいなため、「売り上げを伸ばす」よりは「経費を節減する」方がすぐに効果が出やすいのです。
ソフトウェアのように粗利益率が高い業界（例えば60パーセント）で、経費を１〜２パーセント削っても利益率に対する効果はわずかですが、特に効果が大きいのは、売上きぼは大きいものの営業利益率が1〜3％しかない業界です。
売上の1％に相当する経費を削減できれば、営業利益が数十％から倍増することもあります。
note株式会社がそれに当てはまるかどうかは知りませんが、エーアイの導入の際に、上の話を意識するのは悪くないと思います。
【質問】
エーアイを使う際，今は従量課金制でクレジットをどのくらい使ったかを気にしながら作業しています。
社内でもエーアイを導入するにあたり，いかにクレジット消費を抑えつつ導入するか　といった議論になることもあります。
個人的にはそんなことはエーアイ普及の初期段階における懸念であって長期的には小事，将来的にはインターネットのように定額で我々は何回使ったかなど意識する必要もない時代になる という気もしますが，一方エーアイは使っただけ電力をしょうひするということで長期的にも従量課金制は続く　という可能性もあるのかなとも思い，今クレジット消費を抑える活用方法を真剣に検討する必要があるのかどうか考えているのですが，中島さんの見解を伺いたいです。
《回答》
とても興味深い話なので、この問題には注目し続ける必要があると感じています。
私自身は、Claude Codeの定額課金（月額200ドル）を最大限使っているので、これが従量課金になってしまうと困ります。
幸いなことに、オープン・ウェイトなモデルも順調なペースで進歩しているので、アンソロピックも簡単には従量課金に移行できないと期待しています。
なので、現時点では、可能な限り従量課金を避け、定額課金のモデルを使い（月額200ドル程度は、仕事のためであれば十分に許容範囲だと思います）、いざという時（アンソロピックが従量課金に踏み切った時）にオープン・ウェイトなモデルに切り替えられるように準備しておくのが、最も現実的な戦略だと思います。
以上で今回の放送を終わります。
またお聞きください。